here are more shocking things celebs
revealed in their Memoirs Prince Harry
revealed in his Memoir spare that he
actually believed that his mother had
faked her own death because of how
miserable he said her life was he
believed that she had staged the
accident as a diversion and then run
away for four years he hoped that she
would come back he eventually asked the
driver to take him on the same route
that his mom was on when she died and he
said that he didn't get the closure he
wanted and that it was a very bad idea
Danny Trejo revealed that when he was 17
and he was in jail he actually got
hypnotized by Charles Manson Trejo and
Charles Manson were both being held at
the L.A County Jail in exchange for
protection he told Trejo and the other
jail mates that he could hypnotize them
to make them feel like they were high
without actually doing any drugs it
actually worked and Trejo said that
Manson could have been a professional
hypnotist finally Melissa joined heart
revealed that she was experimenting with
lots of drugs while she was filming
Sabrina the Teenage Witch this includes
mushrooms and ecstasy in fact she claims
she was once offered Coke by Paris
Hilton but chose not to partake